hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
a new commander-in-chief promising a new
chapter
but amid a deadly pandemic and a divided
america
how will the biden administration tackle
toxic political polarization
plaguing the country fox news special
report anchor bret baer weighs in
on what challenges lie ahead and what
the incoming president must do to make
good on his promises
to heal the soul of the nation and
address the needs of every american
president trump's relationship with news
organizations and tech companies
hasn't been all sunshine howie kurtz
host of media buzz the media buzzmeter
podcast and author
of media madness donald trump the press
and the war over the truth
shares his insight on social media
platforms banning the president
and how he thinks the biden
administration will handle the press
plus commentary from fox news
contributor pastor robert jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
hammer i'm janis dean i'm juan williams
and this is the
fox news rundown
wednesday january 20th 2021
i'm lisa brady the united states gets a
new president today
but how quickly anything else changes is
up in the air
there will be pressure uh to do things
bigger to do things
bolder uh the challenge though
is for his administration to kind of
walk through
the slim majorities that they have i'm
dave anthony
the trump to biden transition may end an
era of the president versus the press
the president's gonna miss donald trump
it is no secret
that most of the media were not fans of
the president covered him in an
overwhelmingly negative fashion
sometimes he deserved it sometimes he
didn't
and there was a lot of visceral
hostility there but
he was good for business and i'm robert
jeffress i've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
just two weeks after the deadly assault
on the u.s capitol
a fundamental american tradition the
peaceful
transfer of power in washington
inauguration day
though the nation's capital is on
lockdown with thousands of national
guard troops on duty
for joe biden swearing in as the 46th
u.s
president the 45th recording a farewell
video
released late tuesday afternoon we did
what we came here to do and so
much more president trump taking a
somewhat subdued victory lap
on the pre-pandemic economy foreign
policy and as he puts it
restoring the principle that a nation
exists to serve its citizens
our agenda was not about right or left
it wasn't about republican or democrat
but about the good
of a nation and that means the whole
nation
he also said political violence can
never be tolerated
offering best wishes to the new
president and prayers
for keeping the nation safe and
prosperous joe biden spent the eve of
his inauguration
attending a memorial for the more than
four hundred thousand
lives lost to covet in the u.s
to heal we must remember
it's hard sometimes to remember
but that's how we heal he says it's
important to do that as a nation
earlier in the day biden wiped away
tears as he paid tribute to his late son
beau
during a send-off event in his home
state delaware and also
offered hope i know these are dark times
but there's always light he inherits a
nation
devastated by the pandemic and deeply
divided
we'll hear a lot about unity i think in
in biden's speech bret baer is fox's
chief political anchor and the host of
special report
on fox news channel really the question
becomes
what the actions look like uh to
get the 74 million voters who voted for
president trump
uh at least on the same page
when it comes to trying to get things
done for the country
yeah i mean is there something that joe
biden needs to say
specifically when he addresses the
country and really the world
at this event the world is looking in
and uh it doesn't really understand what
has happened and i think
there's a lot of americans who look at
it and don't fully understand january 6
was a
major moment and the images and
all that surrounded that moment
really will be in the history books so
the challenge for joe biden
is to get beyond that and to say
something
that can possibly unite both his
progressive side of his party
and the people again 75 million or 74
million
who voted for donald trump it's a big
challenge as far as the speech goes
to say the least um there and there have
been a lot of questions raised about the
future of the republican party and the
divide in the republican party but the
democratic party does have a lot of
those same
questions at least on some level and i
wanted to ask you about the progressive
wing of the democratic party i mean
do you think that the focus on the
pandemic will ease
any of the early pressure that biden
might have faced
from progressives or is he looking at a
short
honeymoon either way well i do think
that they're going to give him some
leeway but
uh there will be pressure uh to do
things bigger to do things
bolder the challenge though
is for his administration to kind of
walk
through the slim majorities that they
have 50 50 in the senate just a few
seats for house speaker nancy pelosi
it's not going to be easy to get
big bold transformational things through
with
this kind of configuration and he has to
articulate that to the left side of his
party
and likely has to negotiate on on all
sides
certainly tackling kovid will be the
first thing
on his agenda as the new president what
else
should he or could he try to address
early on
or is it is it a mistake to even try to
address anything else
right away until things start to
turn a corner in the pandemic well i
think there'll be a lot
that falls into the covid basket
legislatively
and you know i think the republicans
will make a lot of noise about that but
you're already starting to see the
proposals come out about
a minimum wage increase that is you know
in the covid relief um and
other things as well state and local
support
different elements of his legislative
proposal that'll all
fall under the biden's terminology under
the covid
name i i do think that there will be an
effort for
some kind of immigration legislation but
uh without a change in the filibuster in
other words getting
60 votes for that legislation in the
senate
without blowing that up uh i think it's
tough to get those numbers
with the current configuration i know
west virginia senator joe manchin
i believe he has said he's he would not
be in favor of eliminating the
filibuster rule
which again would mean a simple majority
for
more things or most things um would be
possible
so if he's against it then there doesn't
really seem to be
the appetite for it i mean is he is he
sort of the last line
of defense for opponents of eliminating
the the filibuster rule
i think so i mean i i don't think we've
we've got a full sense from people like
kirsten cinema or mark kelly the
the newest senator from arizona
all other senators seem to indicate on
the democratic side that they
might be in favor of blowing up the
filibuster you know what that means is
that
the all of that legislation would only
need 51
and there could be big sweeping changes
that include adding states like the
district
of columbia and puerto rico that's all
about
power about power consolidation
so far manchin has said and he said on
special report recently
that he does not want to do that has no
interest in blowing up the filibuster
we'll see there's a lot of pressure and
there will be a lot of pressure
for legislative agenda items presidents
are prone to a last round of pardons and
commutations on their way out the door
regardless of the specifics of that this
time
is that a mistake for president trump or
does it not
really matter in the big picture right
now because of the second impeachment
and the upcoming senate trial of him
yeah i mean every president on his way
out the door
has some pardons and commutations um
this list may be longer we'll see but
we'll see who's on the list i think
that's the biggest uh
the biggest question mark you remember
back in bill clinton's time he pardoned
mark
rich and there was all kinds of uh
investigation about how that came to be
how these pardons and commutations come
to be
as part of it may be looked into by
congress now controlled by democrats in
all the investigative committees
i read a column um in recent days by
fox's chad pergram who as you know has
spent so many years working at the
capitol
and he was suggesting just as it was
people
who breach the capital ultimately it'll
be people
who can bridge the divides in this
country which is obviously much easier
said than done
what would you say to offer people hope
well i would say look to history and uh
look to all the things that our country
has been through
i mean we're a resilient country and yes
we are
very divided currently politically no
matter where you stand
ideologically the getting back to the
constitution
and what founding fathers really wanted
i think is the ultimate goal for
politicians
when when they start out and you know
democrats now talking a lot about the
constitution and
in the impeachment trial republicans
talking about a lot of about the
constitution following the rules
if you go back to those first principles
that's kind of our our north star and
i think resilience is a good message uh
we are a resilient country
and uh it might be a bumpy road but
we'll get there
any of us who are parents think about
the state of the country and the future
of it through the lens
of what's coming for our children for
anyone who doesn't know though you've
had
more much more pressing personal
concerns
for your son paul since since birth five
congenital heart defects multiple
surgeries
um at children's national hospital and i
know there's an event coming up
to benefit that wonderful facility i
want to ask you first though
how is paul doing how's he doing now
he's doing well thanks for asking he's
uh
he's 13. he just finished his fourth
open heart surgery uh
seven weeks ago and he is on the manned
recovering he's
chipping and putting and soon we'll be
back uh full swing in his
love of golf so uh he's doing great and
we're very blessed to have children's
national they're also
they also do a lot of work with research
on congenital
heart defects that affects the world and
they're on the brink of
a lot of breakthroughs so we try to
raise money every year
and we're doing this event we usually do
it in naples florida
but since covid uh this year we're
opening up to the nation
and it's allstarpanelevent.com
allstarpanelevent.com and it'll be a
panel brian kilmeade charles payne
shannon bream
emily compagno and myself talking about
the future
of the country taking questions from
people who are logged on
we'll have special guests and
performances by rascal flatts and all
kinds of folks
who you know well and then the best part
is that there's this auction
that will have that you can get things
like uh
zoom with greg gutfeld uh or
jim nance will do your phone message on
your cell phone
you know hello friends um you know kind
of stuff that's really unique
that i think will be raised a lot of
money for the hospital every dollar
goes to children's nationals so
allstarpanelevent.com it's february 13th
that's amazing and i've actually heard
that some fundraisers
are going um you know better than you
might think in the virtual
format because it's kind of easier for
people to log in
and to donate and join that way than it
would be to get there in person
yeah definitely i mean we had 800 people
or so in naples is an amazing event this
is the fourth year going
and we raise more and more money every
year but in the covered
world we thought why not open up to
everybody
and uh it'll be highly produced and
we'll have a great event and then this
auction
will last for like three or four days
where you can bid on stuff and we'll
raise a lot of money i think
well let's hope for children's national
hospital excellent and i'm
i'm glad to hear that paul's latest
surgery has gone well
and that he's recovering from it and we
always appreciate your time don't miss
special report folks
with fox's bret bear thank you very very
much brent
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up a lot can change
with a new president taking over
including how he's covered in the press
the media are among the most dishonest
people
anywhere at any time president trump
battled newspapers and networks over
stories he didn't believe i want you all
to know that we are fighting the fake
news
it's fake and often times in a tweet or
a speech he would call the press he
didn't like
the enemy of the people and they are
they are the enemy of the people
but president trump did talk to
reporters a lot over the past four years
in office
and i don't mind being criticized but
not when they're wrong
and sometimes things got testy between
you people don't answer don't talk to me
that way
you're just a you're just a lightweight
don't talk to me that way don't talk to
i'm the president of the united states
don't ever talk to the president that
way
but i'm going to go with another
question go ahead now joe biden takes
over
with likely a different approach it is
the end of an era in many ways the end
of the era for the country
after a highly contested election
which continued for weeks and weeks and
weeks with the charges of a stolen
election
howie kurtz is host of media buzz on the
fox news channel and the media buzz
meter podcast
living here in washington is kind of an
amazing spectacle
you know you've got major portions of
the city shut down more than 20 000
national guard troops
uh and that's the backdrop for the
inauguration
uh for joe biden um it's
kind of a reminder of the insurrection
at the capitol just a couple of weeks
ago
that led to donald trump's impeachment
and also you won't have the usual
adoring crowds and that's
a casualty of cobin 19. so uh it is the
beginning of a new era but i kind of
feel like the trump
show is not yet completely played out
well
he's silenced on social media and it was
kind of weird he ended his presidency so
quiet because he
so many tweets for so many years that we
were so accustomed to
but now what i mean he where does he go
from here
well he goes from here to a senate
impeachment trial uh by law after the
house
impeached him all democrats 10
republican votes as you know
you know i had his former deputy white
house press secretary
hogan gidley on my media buzz program
the other day
and hogan said well you know the press
wants it both ways because
they are happy that big tech mainly
twitter
you know knocked the president's account
offline
and permanently bans him and then they
say where's the president why haven't we
heard from him well the counter to that
is
at least through yesterday he was still
the president of the united states
he could talk to reporters anytime he
want he could grant television
interviews he could hold a news
conference he could just walk into the
briefing room
and everybody would take it live i think
he has chosen
um to remain quieter he has released a
couple of videos
but it is true i mean he loved that
280 character form of twitter
communication
and i have some problems with it as a
free speech matter i can understand the
temporary suspension
in light of the violence and potential
for violence i don't understand
doing it to donald trump private citizen
but when i say the trump show is
continuing
i mean i think it's unfortunate for a
new president who is coming into office
as biden is
facing you know the height of a awful
pandemic and a crippled economy
will in effect have a split screen
presidency for at least a while
as we see when the senate trial starts
and how long it takes to conclude
the president often called the media and
the press
the enemy of the people especially the
new york times or the washington post he
was combative with his made for tv like
news conferences
how different do you expect joe biden to
be
yeah trump didn't like cnn by the way
let's let's leave that one out
before do you think i i think we're
going to see a completely
different year uh in several respects
first of all you know
the press is going to miss donald trump
it's no secret
that most of the media were not fans of
the president covered him in an
overwhelmingly negative fashion
sometimes he deserves
sometimes he didn't and there was a lot
of visceral hostility there but
he was good for business he was a
business model clicks
ratings up for all of the networks all
the websites all the national newspapers
and their digital subscriptions
so in that sense the constant drama some
would say chaos of the trump years
uh probably is it's going to affect the
bottom line
for many media corporations in another
way and every journalist even though
ones who just despise donald trump had
to acknowledge that he was by far
the most accessible president of modern
times he would take questions five or
six times a day you know
standing in front of the helicopter on
the plane when he landed for the trip
um and he obviously made a lot of news
off plus the twitter feed which you
mentioned earlier i mean every
every sunday morning i'd have my staff
email trump tweeted this trump tweeted
that we got to get into the show
all that's going to change under biden
for these reasons first of all joe biden
ran not just on unity but sort of
lowering the temperature in the country
i don't think he wants to make as much
news as donald trump did we saw that
during the campaign he doesn't want to
be
in the public space every single hour
every single day secondly
he's not going to talk to reporters as
much maybe as much as
george w bush did or obama bill clinton
which is a historical norm
and finally we're going to see daily
press briefings coming back after
uh up and down uh and at times hiatus
during the trump administration jen saki
the incoming white house press secretary
uh is going to brief for her deputies
you know just about every day so it's
going to be
a sea change and a big adjustment for
the mainstream media
do you think that she is going to face
the same kind of questions
that the press secretaries under
president trump
in sometimes hostile news conferences
would face i think there are times
when there'll be a rough back and forth
between jen saki and the press corps she
did this at state department uh under
president obama she also was the white
house communications director
and you know we get into when when the
when joe biden as president
over a period of time owns the pandemic
owns the economy
uh all the promises uh you know
obviously are not going to be kept all
at once
there'll be some rough back and forth do
i think it's going to resemble anything
like
the raucous and sometimes hostile and
often negative
uh relationship between uh reporters and
for example sean spicer or sarah
huckabee sanders
or kelly macanally no i don't and
there's a danger here for the media
which is look
they're not the same uh we're not
talking about uh we'll be talking about
new president who hasn't been impeached
who doesn't consciously stir the pot of
controversy
as frequently and as vociferously as
donald trump does
but who nevertheless needs to be covered
aggressively and held accountable
especially he made a lot of promises in
the campaign as every president does
if the press fails to do that if the
press briefings or the times that
uh biden opts to hold the news
conference are
you know our softball affairs our love
fest
then everybody is going to see
particularly the 75 million people who
voted for president trump
uh that there's a double stand in the
media i hope that doesn't happen but i
can't say i'm optimistic
you mentioned the uh trump supporters
you've probably seen some of the things
that have been on other networks
uh cnn or msnbc where people talk about
some of these trump supporters
need to be deprogrammed i mean there's
new quinnipiac poll the other day that
talked about two-thirds of republicans
still don't think that
that joe biden was elected legitimately
and alexandria ocasio-cortez the
congresswoman from new york the democrat
the progressive
she had this to say about the media
maybe
the media more on the conservative side
and what's your reaction after we hear
from aoc
we're going to have to figure out
how we reign in our media environment
so that you can't just spew
disinformation and misinformation
it's one thing to have differing
opinions but
um it's another thing entirely to just
say things that are false so how
would someone in congress reign in the
media
well actually there's a thing called the
first amendment that prevents you from
reigning in the media there is no
role for government uh when it comes to
regulating media content now
lots of members of congress of both
parties have complained about
misinformation and disinformation on
social media because
facebook and twitter in my view have
done such an awful job they keep saying
they're going to improve and that never
quite happens
uh in curtailing hate speech violence
beach uh
bullying and things like that because
they don't really
view themselves as media companies when
in fact they're very powerful
media companies i do have to say uh
alessandra ocasio-cortez in that same
instagram video it was it was soon after
the attack on the capitol
uh she said she thought she was going to
die i don't know that she's thought this
through she just said some democrats are
talking about
a commission or something there's no
legislation to react to but i don't
think that will get anywhere
uh when it comes to regulating the media
because of the tradition of freedom and
the press in this country
what do you think happens with social
media you have the whole controversy
over parlor
uh the social media conservative side
that was shut down with amazon and apple
and google
there are critics who are on the right
that say look a lot of the stuff that
that was objected to on parlor is on
twitter and not taken down so they don't
understand
yeah i i don't think i'm troubled by the
way that apple amazon google got
together
to knock parlor offline and it has
become a conservative alternative for
many on the right
on the other hand i've seen a lot of
really bad threats
on parlor that were allowed to stay
there including threats against amazon
which is people can understand
i mean death threats against jeff bezos
and why don't we
blow up amazon servers and that sort of
thing all the social media companies
need to do a better job but
um i hope paula is able to come back
just because i believe in you know
healthy discourse if we can keep some of
the most dangerous garbage
off of these websites the subtitle of
your book the media madness book about
president trump
was the war over the truth that
both sides claim to have the truth in in
this in this ongoing debate that we have
the word truth seems to have been
obfuscated some do you agree
yeah i totally agree uh that's why i use
the subtitle i mean i think
we have a world right now that is so
polarized and i
will candidly tell you that i think the
media including all the cable news
networks have contributed
to the polarization and deep divisions
in american society because that's how
you get attention and you get you build
audiences by playing
to that um it seems to me that you know
as the poll you cited earlier i mean
right now joe biden will begin his
administration although he you know
clearly won the electoral college and he
won by seven million popular votes
uh with a significant chunk of the
country not just wishing president trump
had one but believing president trump's
repeated allegations
which remain unproven which were not
upheld in any court of law or by his own
justice department
that the election was stolen when the
election was not stolen but
a lot of people believe that that's
going to be a difficult
environment in which for joe biden to
govern it however
i think his lower key approach it's
harder to demonize joe biden i mean you
may agree with his politics he may not
agree with his politics
he's been around forever he's 36 years
in the senate eight years as vice
president
78 years old i think if he's going to
have a chance of success and he'll be
judged
by those twin challenges of the pandemic
and the economy
it will be if he can lower the
temperature
uh and while i don't think anybody
people on capitol hill going to suddenly
be singing
kumbaya the fact that he's going to go
to church today with mitch mcconnell
before being sworn in i think it's a
nice bit of symbolism
for how biden would like to start his
term howie kurtz host of the media buzz
on the fox news channel in the media
buzz meter podcast always good to talk
to you thanks for joining us
thanks very much
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind four years ago i was
getting ready to preach a sermon
but no it wasn't in my home pulpit at
the first baptist church of dallas
it was at the historic saint john's
episcopal church in washington d.c
with president-elect donald trump and
vice president mike pence
just before their inauguration on that
day i said clearly and
unequivocally that god had raised up a
builder to help meet our nation's
challenges
that probably does not surprise you but
what might surprise you is
if i had been invited to preach a sermon
today to president joe biden
and vice president kamala harris i would
have been able to stand in that pulpit
and preach the very
same truths from god's unchanging word
back in january of 2017 i said
the challenges facing our nation are so
great that it will take more than
natural ability to meet them
we need god's supernatural power
the good news is that the same god who
empowered nehemiah nearly 2500 years ago
is available to every one of us today
who is willing to humble himself
and ask for god's help this truth holds
true
yesterday today and forever god can help
us in the midst of our troubles
there is one thing we know for certain
about politics
there will always be troubles everything
we
fix breaks back down every problem we
solve
crops back up every obstacle we cross
leads to more that's just life in a
broken
sinful world politics has aptly been
called
the science of muddling through we just
do the best we can
with what we've got we faced many
challenges that seemed
insurmountable in january of 2017
and now 2017 seems like a lifetime ago
we are nearly a year into a global
pandemic that rages on
we've experienced tremendous political
and social unrest
many people are hurting economically and
have lost their jobs
no amount of human wisdom can solve
these problems
we need to call on god if president
biden and vice president harris
humble themselves and ask for god's help
scripture tells us
he will answer god is no respecter of
persons the bible says
he doesn't see r or d next to your name
when you pray to him
he looks for a willing contrite heart
god promises in psalm 50 verse 15
call upon me in the day of trouble i
shall rescue you
and you will honor me as i watch what is
happening in our nation today i'm not in
a pessimistic mood
god has not been caught by surprise god
remains on his throne
and thankfully his reign is not in doubt
or up for a vote
the good news that i preach every sunday
is while we still have breath in our
lungs
it's never too late for us to repent and
turn
and be reconciled to god through jesus
christ
things may be dark but the same god who
told light to shine out of the darkness
can do so again in our nation our cities
our neighborhoods and our families
beginning with us
our nation's brightest days may yet lie
ahead
out beyond the horizon of today's
squabbles and troubles
we don't get to choose what the
challenges are but we can choose
how to meet them we can go it alone or
we can call upon god
i am praying for america today as i was
four years ago
that we will choose to unite around a
shared trust
in the king of kings this is robert
jeffress
for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes